[Music]
jude is the light of my life
he's
on the autism spectrum
and so that makes him extra special
justin justin i don't want him to be
stuck in just video game world
[Music]
hiking can bring you strength
and i want to impart some of that to him
my parents they tried to raise me to be
a traditional latina
when they thought of outdoor activities
it was meant for boys so i was told no
didn't always work i seemed to always
find a way to break the rules
[Music]
2012 was a pivotal year for me my mother
was diagnosed with stage four lung
cancer
while she was in hospice
my son's father decided that he wanted
to end our six-year relationship
and then my mother died two days later
[Music]
my son was four and a half
it all
just
shattered me
[Music]
i was in a really dark place
i literally one day i had this urge to
get out
getting to the top of mountain is a
journey
i've learned so much about myself and
what i'm capable of by taking that
journey
i want you to feel sensitive
accomplishment himself when we finish a
hype
jude does not
particularly love hiking i have tried to
get him outdoors i push him
i want him to expand his horizon
i do worry about his future
i want him to be happy i want him to
find love
[Music]
come here
let's try that one is that good yeah all
right cool
you want to lead the way
i guess all right you're too slow i'm
too slow
what
seriously but they look pretty don't
they
all these things that i've struggled
through
when
it comes to the end of the day what
keeps me sane is knowing that jude is
okay
because he is the light of my life and
hearing his voice
seeing him cuddling with him it makes
just about everything go away
there's a bunch of flowers
yeah what do you think those are
no lupines and they're losing
that's a dangerous one because she told
me oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you